a millionaire accused of killing his
wife is expected in court in California
today after more than four years on the
run we told you yesterday about Peter
Chadwick he vanished after he was
charged with murder but was caught in
Mexico Sunday well today prosecutors
will ask a judge to deny bail 48 hours
correspondent Tracy Smith shows us how
Chadwick avoided law enforcement for so
long we believe that Peter Chadwick has
been in Mexico since his disappearance
law enforcement says Peter Chadwick used
aliases and fake IDs to live off the
grid for more than four years the 55
year old vanished in 2015 after being
charged with murdering his wife QC in
their Newport Beach home while their
children were at school at a news
conference Tuesday authorities said
Chadwick tried throwing off
investigators Chadwick strategically
placed indicators that he was headed to
Canada and his father's residence they
say he was actually hiding out in Mexico
first at high-end resorts then at motels
and hostels working odd jobs to make
money even though he fled with nearly a
million in cash he went from a real
estate millionaire to bussing tables
right I think he was just desperate to
fit in and stay on the run so this is
where he stopped
officials say intense coverage by media
including 48 hours put pressure on
Chadwick the media coverage made him
trip up I believe so yeah I think that
caused an incredible amount of stress in
his life Chadwick faces 25 years to life
in prison for CBS this morning Tracy
Smith Los Angeles and you can watch
Tracy Smith's 48 hours report Peter
Chadwick captured that Saturday at 10:00
9:00 central right here on CBS